[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers ihn
allen guten Abend die überwältigende
Bedrohung von außen schweißt zusammen im
Innern aus erbitterten Gegner die sich
gerade noch vorgeworfen haben das Land
in die Diktatur zu führen werden
Koalitionspartner gerade noch
Massenproteste auf israelsstraßen jetzt
Regierung und Opposition gemeinsam ein
kriegskabinett allein das zeigt schon
auf was sich Israel für die kommende
Zeit einstellt vielleicht einstellen
muss die andere Seite das ist zunächst
mal das islamistische Terrorregime von
Gaza das sind aber auch die Menschen die
unter ihm in Gaza leben müssen und und
gerade massive Bombardements der
israelischen Luftwaffe
erdulden der Gazastreifen ist
flächenmäßig deutlich kleiner als Köln
weit über 2 Millionen Menschen leben
hier abgeriegelt von Israel und Ägypten
180 000 von ihnen sind bereits innerhalb
von Gaza auf der Flucht heute um 14 Uhr
hat das Elektrizitätswerk seinen Betrieb
eingestellt es war das einzige in
Gaza der Strom ist weg er und
Lebensmittel werden knapp israel hatte
bereits angekündigt es werde keine
Versorgung mehr leisten l walport aus
telaviv der Himmel über Südisrael heute
Abend hamasraketen aus dem Gazastreifen
sie werden in der Luft
abgefangen der Himmel über Nordisrael Z
Stunden vorher Luftalarm Fernsehsender
zeigen eine Drohne die aus dem Libanon
eingedrungen sei ein Fehlalarm wie sich
herausstellt das war eine israelische
druhe
ist spürbar am Morgen trat das
Sicherheitskabinett unter Regierungschef
Netanyahu zusammen wie groß ist die
Bedrohung und wie antwortet Israel
später Stimmen Teile der Opposition der
Bildung einer Notstandsregierung zu ein
kriegskabinett trifft jetzt die
Entscheidungen die Armee setzt ihren
Aufmarsch fort rund um den Gazastreifen
immer mehr Soldaten Panzer atillerie
gehen in Stellung während die
Luftangriffe auf Hamas zele weitergehen
die Zahl der Toten Gasastreifen steigt
die Versorgungslage ist dramatisch es
gibt keinen Strom Wasser Lebensmittel
und Medikamente werden
knapp heute früh stand ich noch mit
meinem Nachbarn vor dem Laden jetzt
erfahre ich dass er und seine Familie
von der Bombe getroffen
wurden wir sind vertrieben ich bin hier
meine Kinder an einem anderen Ort der
Rest der Familie noch woers die Lage ist
sehr
schwer die Krankenhäuser sindüber nicht
nur mit Verletzten auch mit
Schutzsuchenden die Vereinten Nationen
erhielten von Ägypten eine Zusicherung
dass die Grenze nach Gaza geöffnet
werde das Gebiet zählt jetzt 263 000
Binnenflüchtlinge Männer Frauen Kinder
40% mehr als
gestern in Israel müssen die Menschen
derweil täglich neue grausame Details
des brutalen terrorüberfalls der Hamas
verarbeiten wie hier im kibutzberi wo
die Terroristen 17 Stunden lang wüteten
und die Armee D Tage brauchte um den Ort
unter Kontrolle zu
bringen wir dachten zunächst wir hätten
beri schon befreit aber immer wieder
kamen Gruppen von Terroristen aus ihren
Verstecken und griffen uns an das war
ein sehr verlustreicher
Kampf die Überwachungskameras zeigen die
Ankunft der Terroristen kurz vor am
Eingangstor Sekunden später das erste
Opfer sie gingen von Haus zu Haus Kinder
wurden erst gefesselt dann enthauptet
andere gleich erschossen oder
verschleppt ein
Massaker Michael beverung ist heute
wieder bei uns unser Israel
Korrespondent ist an der Grenze zum
Gazastreifen und er war heute im kibutz
beri wohin die israelische Armee eine
Pressegruppe geführt hat guten Abend
Michael was was waren das für
Eindrücke
das sind grausame Eindrücke aus einer
Totenstadt die in Teilen noch völlig
intakt scheint ein Gemeindezentrum mit
einem Saal wo noch die Lichter brennen
wo man sich vorstellt dass vor kurzem
noch Leute dort gelacht gefeiert haben
ein paar Meter weiter totale Zerstörung
von den Kämpfen der letzten Tage es hat
drei Tage bis zum Montag gedauert bis
die Armee wirklich diesen Ort komplett
befreit hat zurückgek kämpft hat und nur
der Leichengeruch der überall noch liegt
lässt eine ahn welche furchtbaren Szenen
sich da abgespielt haben müssen ein
Soldat hat mich zur Seite genommen und
sagte bitte erzähl das der Welt was ich
hier gesehen habe habe ich so noch nicht
erlebt ich habe
thuptete Kinder gesehen Kinder die mit
gefesselten Beinen mit Kabelbindern
gefesselt waren und dann in dem
Schutzraum wo man sie aufgespürt hat
erschossen hat und er er rang nach
Worten und sagte hier werden immer viele
ver gezogen aber ich muss den einen
Vergleich ziehen es ist wie ein Pogrom
im Holocaust und
inzwischen wieder ein anderes Bild ist
Beeri ein aufmarschraum geworden
hunderte von Soldaten Panzer das liegt
wirklich nur 34 km vom gaserstreifen von
der Grenze entfernt hier macht sich die
Armee bereit für die Offensive aufgaser
und diese Soldaten werden wahrscheinlich
zur ersten Welle gehören wenn es zur
Boden off kommt und die Regierung in
Israel ist jetzt eine der sogenannten
nationalen Einheit und da stellt sich
natürlich die Frage wie viel Einheit
gibt's da wirklich wer hat denn jetzt
das Kommando über die militärischen
Aktionen z.B ist da auch Streit zu
erwarten Streit in diesem Land immer
die unmittelbare Führung wird jetzt eine
Art triumvat
übernehmen bestehend aus dem
Premierminister Benjamin Netanyahu sein
Verteidigungsminister Galland und neu
Benny Garz der war schon mal
Verteidigungsminister ist übrigens auch
exgeneralstatschef hat also militärische
experti Expertise dieses triumirat soll
Israel durch den Krieg führen das
Kabinett muss zwar die Entscheidung
abnicken aber es ist davon auszugehen
dass die die Entscheidung treffen werden
was fehlt ist der eigentliche
Oppositionsführer ja irlaaped er hat
gesagt er tritt nur dann in eine
Regierung ein wenn die Extremisten auf
aus den siedlerparteien ausgeschlossen
werden das konnte er nicht durchsetzen
trotzdem ist schon eine Art
innenpolitische Befriedung eingetreten
denn die Bedingung war von Garz dass
alle Gesetzesvorhaben die nicht den
Krieg betreffen ausgesetzt werden also
der ganze Streit um diese Justizreform
und die Gewaltenteilung die wird erstmal
vorläufig adakta gelehnt Michael berunge
mit schrecklichen Eindrücken von Vorort
und den politischen Eindrücken und der
Analyse Michael herzlichen Dank dafür
auch heute abend nach Israel der UNO
Hochkommissar für Menschenrechte hat
klar gemacht dass es nach humanitärem
Völkerrecht verboten ist Menschen das
vorzuenthalten was sie zum Leben
brauchen auch der natochf appelliert an
Israel die Antwort auf Hamas müsse
verhältnismäßig sein wie er sagt goline
atai beobachtet für uns dass in Kairo
goline guten Abend ist denn jemand
aktuell bei dir in der arabischen Welt
zu erkennen der jetzt vermitteln
könnte nein aktuell sehe ich niemanden
die Arabische Liga die müsste eigentlich
aus ihrer langen Letargie aufwachen und
eine Initiative starten aber die
Außenminister der Arabischen Liga die
heute in Kairo getagt haben die haben
keine solche Initiative angekündigt dass
und das nur bei den üblichen Appellen
belassen wir wissen nur dass die USA mit
Ägypten in Kontakt steht Ägypten ist der
erste der wichtigste Vermittler
eigentlich schon seit Jahren und und wir
wissen dass die USA offenbar auch mit
Katar in Kontakt stehen Katar hat sich
wohl selber angeboten sich einzuschalten
in Sachen geiselverhandlungen mit der
Hamas morgen ist der Emir von Qatar
übrigens in Berlin beim Bundeskanzler
und Bundespräsidenten israel hat gesagt
sie sollen fliehen zu den Menschen in
Gaza zumindest aus ihren Stadtvierteln
denn ganze Stadtviertel liegen bereits
in Schutt und Asche das ist natürlich
leichter gesagt als getan in diesem
abgeriegelten Küstenstreifen wie ist
denn die Rolle von Ägypten warum lässt
Ägypten die Menschen nicht in groß im
Stil einfach über die Grenze
Ägypten befürchtet dass hier Tatsachen
geschaffen werden für Ägypten ist das
ganze was in Israel und in Gaza passiert
eine Frage der eigenen nationalen
Sicherheit also die Nervosität in
Sicherheitskreisen ist hier wirklich
sehr spürbar auf der einen Seite gibt es
in der Bevölkerung große Solidarität mit
den Palästinensern und auf der anderen
Seite will die Regierung die öffentliche
Kritik an Israel dämpfen weil sie sonst
Chaos und Gewalt befürchtet einerseits
bereitet man sich hier vor auf
medizinische Notfälle aus Gaza
andererseits haben Sicherheitskreise die
Befürchtung dass dieser Konflikt darauf
hinauslaufen wird dass eine große Masse
von Palästinensern aus Gasa
hinausgedrängt wird und in die Sinai
Halbinsel hineingedrängt wird dass also
Ägypten die die Hoheit über seine
Grenzen verliert die Souveränität und
das ist etwas was Sicherheitskreise hier
der Sicherheitsapparat auf jeden Fall
verhindern möchte Israel könne ein
Problem das es selbst habe es müsse es
selber lösen und nicht auf Ägypten
abwälzen das wir hören wir hier immer
wieder go herzlichen Dank nach
Deutschland das Hohe Haus ganz still der
Deutsche Bundestag hat heute der Opfer
des Hamas Terrors in Israel
gedacht mit einer Schweigeminute
Bundestagspräsidentin berbelb sprach
danach von beispiellosem Terror dabei
waren auch der Bundespräsident und der
israelische Botschafter in Deutschland
in den jüdischen Gemeinden bei uns
findet man unzählige die direkt
verwandte Freunde Bekannte haben die
diesen beispiellosen Terror Vorort
miterleben mussten und viele jüdische
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Deutschland
machen sich auch hier zunehmend Sorge
wie Stefan mersburger
berichtet Abendgebet in einer Berliner
Synagoge sie trauern um die Opfer des
hamasterrors und wollen ihre
Unterstützung für Israel zum Ausdruck
bringen die Gemeinde ist
aufgewühlt das kann man eigentlich gar
nicht beschreiben weil man doch ständig
dann wenn man mit den Tränen kämpfen
muss eigentlich weil es ja gar keinen
gibt würde ich behaupten der nicht
wenigstens Freunde oder eben auch
Verwandte oder nahe Verwandte eben in
Israel hat Bilder aus Deutschland auf
denen die Terroristen offen bejubelt und
die Opfer verhöhnt werden schockieren
die Gesellschaft was aber machen diese
Bilder mit deutschen Juden sie müssen
mit Angst vor Gewalt und Antisemitismus
Leben was ich auf jeden Fall verändert
hat ist dass während in Israel Menschen
ermordet worden sind und misshandelt
worden sind das gleichzeitig Leute gab
die sich in Deutschland sicher genug
gefühlt haben diesen Schrecken zu
zelebrieren und dazu aufgerufen haben
mit ihn gemeinsam diesen Terror zu
feiern und das wirkt sich natürlich auf
das Sicherheitsgefühl von Jüdinnen und
Juden in de Deutchland aus es wird ja
sehr verdeckt dass es diesen
muslimischen Antisemitismus gibt und es
steht eigentlich gar nicht zur Debatte
ja wenn ich nicht benennen kann und darf
woher diese Anfeindungen kommen wie soll
ich gegen sie angehen heute wenn ich
rausgehen würde mit ein Kipar selbst in
Berlin Mitte würde ich mich sehr unwohl
fühlen würde ich mich die ganze Zeit
umschauen bei der Jüdischen Allgemeinen
einer Wochenzeitung machen Sie eine
Sonderausgabe sie zeigen Fotos der
Ermordeten und nennen Namen die Idee
dahinter ist dass wir
etwas Bleibendes schaffen wollen mit
unserer Zeitung dass wir eine besondere
Anmutung machen wollen die diesen
schrecklichen Ereignissen gerecht wird
schickt Israel Bodentruppen in den
Gazastreifen steht eine weitere
Eskalation
bevor selbstverständlich wird auch
Israel hohen Preis dafür zahlen und es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass auch die
jüdische Gemeinschaft hier in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird
die Schutzmaßnahmen vor jüdischen
Einrichtungen wurden verstärkt doch wird
das den Bedrohungen gerecht die da
womöglich
kommen selbst mit der dem erhöhten
Risiko auch unabhängig jetzt von dem was
aktuell tagesaktuell da gerade abgeht
ich mich teilweise in Israel trotzdem
sicherer fühle weil ich weiß
dass ich dort im Zweifel geschützt werde
und hier ist das
fraglich heute gab es proalästinensische
Ansammlungen obwohl die Berliner Polizei
solche Demonstrationen aufgrund von
Sicherheitsbedenken verboten hatte die
Polizei nahm Teilnehmer fest einige
äußerten Israel feindliche und
antisemitische
Parolen es ist niemandem zu verdenken
der sich in dieser Welt aktuell nicht
mehr zurecht findet und vor allem nicht
mehr sicher fühlt im Nahen Osten hing
immer schon alles mit allem zusammen und
so sorgt sich Israel vor allem anderen
über einen Krieg an gleich mehreren
Fronten auch wenn der oberste US-Soldat
heute beschwichtigte den USA legen keine
Anzeichen vor dass andere Staaten gegen
Israel vorgehen wollen und es sind nicht
nur die Terrorführer von Hamas und
hiszbollah es gibt noch die ayatollas in
Iran es gibt dann auch natürlich
Nordkoreas Diktator mit seinen
nuklearfantasien es gibt die
chinesischen Drohungen gegen Taiwan und
über den Krieg in Europa der uns seit
fast zwei Jahren entsetzt habe ich noch
gar nicht gesprochen dabei läuft der
auch noch heute war natoreffen kein ein
Krisentreffen sondern eines das gleich
mehrere im Blick haben musste zur selben
Zeit Florian
Neuhann sie haben es ihm heute wieder
und wieder versichert dass da nichts
bröckelt dass ihr nicht zweifeln soll
nicht an der Unterstützung des Westens
nicht an der der USA und dann gibt es
diesen einen Moment der Ehrlichkeit
Mittag Pressekonferenz mit dem
belgischen premier die Frage hat
volodimir selenski Sorge dass der neue
Krieg gegen Israel den alten gegen sein
Land
verdrängt ich bin ehrlich zu ihnen so
wie zu unseren Partner meine Frage war
wird Ihre Unterstützung jetzt
geringer die Partner sagen
nein aber wer wei schon wie das sein
wird denn da ist jetzt ein weiteres Land
dem die USA frische Munition liefern in
der Nacht kommt ein US Frachtflieger mit
den ersten Kisten nach Israel und am
Morgen der ukrainische Präsident
überraschend zur NATO nach Brüssel wo
sich die Verteidigungsminister treffen
protokollarisch eine Liga unter ihm aber
das ist heute egal selenski braucht
weitere Waffen und wirbt zunächst für
Solidarität mit dem nächsten Opfer
mein Ratschlag an alle Regierungschefs
gehen sie nach Israel unterstützen sie
die Menschen die die Terroristen
angreifen was er in Brüssel heute zu
hören bekommt sind Zusagen über neue
Waffen für sein Land von Kampfjets aus
Dänemark und Belgien zur Ausrüstung zur
Minenräumung aus Großbritannien und er
hört viele starke
Worte euer Kampf ist unser Kampf und
eure Sicherheit ist unsere Sicherheit
nicht allein das Problem der Ukraine es
ist auch unsere Verantwortung und
schließlich der
usverteidigungsminister der von
Engpässen angesichts der Lieferung nach
Israel nichts wissen
will natürlich können wir beides tun wir
werden beides tun sie wissen wir sind
das stärkste Land der Welt die USA
können beides machen sagen Sie jetzt sei
Europa erst recht gefragt sagen
Beobachter wirentlen die in Europa und
Sorgen mehr für unsere eigene Sicherheit
in der Ukraine und bei uns und geben den
Amerikanern mehr freie Ressourcen um
Israel zu unterstützen und Deutschland
muss da auch Führung übernehmen
Deutschland kommt heute mit neuen
Zusagen für die Ukraine nach Brüssel
Flugabwehrsysteme Gepard Panzer Fragen
nach einem wanken des Westens wird der
Minister ab bislang gibt's dafür keine
Anzeichen keine Anzeichen das ist die
gute Botschaft des Tages für den Gast
aus der Ukraine die weniger gute
versteckt sich in der kleinen
Einschränkung davor im Wort
bislang tja bislang reden wir noch mit
Elmar tevison unser Mann in Washington
Präsident Biden Elm hat ja ohnehin
Probleme sein Budget durchzubringen
aktuell massive Hilfe für Israel
gleichzeitig enorme Hilfe für die
Ukraine wie lange geht das aus Ussicht
gut also für die Ukraine ist noch Geld
da die US-Regierung hat heutei 3
Millionen noch einmal freigegeben in
Waffen und Munition und das Geld soll
angeblich insgesamt noch bis zum
Jahresende für die Ukraine reichen aber
hier wissen natürlich alle es braucht
jetzt dringend Finanzmittel auch für
Israel und das Interessante ist dass
dieser Angriff vom Samstag eine Art
disziplinierende Wirkung auch auf den
Kongress zu haben scheint die
Republikaner geben sich zumindest Mühe
die Handlungsfähigkeit des Kongresses
wiederherzustellen und es liegt eine
Resolution parat der sich über 400
Abgeordnete anschlie wollen die Israel
Unterstützung zusichert auch
finanzunterstützung Joe Biden der
Präsident will das Nutzen er will jetzt
ein Milliardenpaket vorschlagen das
Militärhilfen nicht nur für Israel
sondern auch für die Ukraine und für
Taiwan beinhaltet und da will er mit
versuchen weil den Republikanern Taiwan
und Israel besonders nah am Herzen liegt
dass er gleich die ukrainehilfe noch
einmal mit bewilligt bekommt ob das
klappt werden wir sehen wir erleben den
Außenminister der gerade hektisch durch
den Nahen Osten telefoniert deshalb
jetzt noch eine Frage an dich Elma die
viele umtreibt viele Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer von uns auch weil die Welt ja
gerade an vielen Stellen brennt wie groß
ist denn die Gefahr aus Ussicht dass
jetzt an noch mehr Brennpunkten die Lage
eskalieren könnte und vielleicht auch
ganz gezielt eskaliert
wird ich glaube das ist der wichtigste
Auftrag für den Außenminister dass er
nicht nur nach Israel fährt der wird
auch nach neu Jordanien gehen
wahrscheinlich in andere arabische
Staaten er steht mit ihnen im Kontakt
weil er ihn vermitteln will und muss
dass die USA sich entschieden haben dass
Israel tatsächlich die Hamas zerstören
und entmachten muss um langfristig aus
dieser endlosen Gewaltspirale
herauszukommen und dass dafür natürlich
am Ende zivile Opfer nicht ganz
vermeidbar sind und um die zu minimieren
wird der intensiv auch mit Ägypten reden
wir haben vorhin das von goline schon
gehört er wird Ägypten vermitteln wollen
dass eben es wichtiger ist jetzt ein ein
Ausweitung dieser Krise zu verhindern
indem man auch die Zahl der zivilen
Opfer minimiert mit anderen Worten die
Grenze öffnet für Flüchtlinge ob das
Ägypten am Ende überzeugen wird auch das
wird man dann sehen MMA TSen Washington
herzlichen
Dank die Energieinfrastruktur ist ebenso
lebenswichtig wie verwundbar Stichwort
nordstream der Anschlag auf die Pipeline
ist ja immer noch ungeklärt jetzt kommen
noch einigermaßen unklare Meldungen über
etw was ein weiterer Anschlag sein
könnte und damit beginnst du jetzt Hanna
die Nachrichten es geht um die Schäden
an der Gaspipeline in der Ostsee
zwischen Finnland und Estland die waren
heute auch Thema beim natogipfel wenn
sich herausstelle dass es sich um einen
Angriff auf kritische natoinrastruktur
handele werde das Bündnis geschlossen
und entschlossen reagieren sagte NATO
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg am Sonntag
war ein Druckabfall in der Pipeline
festgestellt worden die finnische
Regierung nannte Fremdeinwirkung als
wahrscheinliche Ursache die
Untersuchungen dauern
an der Westen Afghanistans ist am Morgen
erneut von einem schweren Erdbeben
erschüttert worden laut US-Angaben hatte
es eine Stärke von 6,3 und war damit
genauso stark wie die Beben am
vergangenen Samstag berichtet wird von
zahlreichen Verletzten und zerstörten
Häusern das genaue Ausmaß der neuen
Schäden ist aber noch unklar auch zu
möglichen gibt es keine gesicherten
Informationen bei den verheerenden Beben
am Wochenende sind laut Medienberichten
mindestens 2000 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen die talibanregierung sprach
zuletzt von über 1000
Toten in der Slowakei steht der
ehemalige Regierungschef fizo kurz davor
erneut Ministerpräsident zu werden der
prorussische linkspopulist einigte sich
11 Tage nach seinem Wahlsieg mit einer
sozialdemokratischen und einer
nationalistischen Partei auf ein
dreiparteienbündnis wann die neue
Regierung vereidigt wird ist noch unklar
ebenso wie die weitere militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine im Wahlkampf
hatte fizo angekündigt die Slowakei
werde dem Land unter seiner Führung
keine Waffen mehr
liefern dass man miteinander reden
sollte das wurde schon länger
vorgeschlagen Angeboten angemahnt je
nachdem aus welcher Ecke man das
betrachtet jetzt wird der Bundeskanzler
reden mit oppositionsfüher Friedrich
märz und zwei Ministerpräsidenten über
ein Thema das die aktuellen
Wahlergebnisse und Umfragen direkt
beeinflusst nämlich wie es weitergehen
soll mit der Migrationspolitik in
Deutschland dass da etwas zu tun wäre
das mahnen die Länder die Städte und
Gemeinden ja bereits seit Monaten an
jetzt kommt Bewegung in die Sache auch
mit einem neuen Gesetzentwurf mattis
feldoff und Andreas hupper mit
Details es sollte eigentlich um
Wirtschaft gehen um die Stärkung der
Industrie die im Dialog doch dann
bestimmt plötzlich der Kurswechsel des
Kanzlers in der Migration die Bühne Olaf
Scholz reagiert auf die Stimmung im Land
und die Wahlergebnisse des Wochenendes
und drückt am Abend aufs Tempo ich habe
veranlasst dass jetzt die ressour
Abstimmung beginnt dass Verbände und
Länder beteiligt werden sod dass wir
noch in diesem Monat auch das Gesetz an
den Deutschen Bundestag weiterleiten
können Ordnung in die Migration bringen
steht über dem Papier schnellere
Abschiebungen von illegalen Flüchtling
Verlängerung des ausreisegewahrsams
Bekämpfung der Schleuser die Ampel ringt
sich durch zu deutlichen Verschärfungen
Erleichterung bei den Abschiebung bei
Rückführung insofern wird es dazu helfen
den Menschen die keine
bleiberechtsperspektive haben in
Deutschland schneller auch wieder in
ihre Länder
zurückzuführen es ist der Jubel der AFD
der die Ampel treibt plötzlich scheint
das möglich was wochenlang innerhalb der
Koalition umstritten war plötzlich
scheint ein Kompromiss mit der Union
denkbar die Rechtspopulisten reklamieren
die migrationswende der Ampel für
sichess wir müssen die Grenzen schützen
wir müssen zurückweisen an den Grenzen
die dublinverordnung lässt das zu das wä
zielführend alles andere sind
Nebelkerzen in Panik die die Regierung
jetzt hat weil sie die Wahlen verloren
hat und die AFD nach vorne kommt
Deutschlands künftige Migrationspolitik
noch scheint die Wahrnehmung über die
Härte des Kurswechsels bei den
Bundesländern umstritten und je nach
Parteizugehörigkeit gefärbt wir haben
das im Mai verabredet jetzt im Oktober
kommt ein
Gesetzentwurf der wird jetzt erstmal
diskutiert im Bundestag ich hoffe es
bleibt möglichst viel erhalten bei den
Debatten insbesondere innerhalb der
Ampel an der Union wird's da sicherlich
nicht hapern auch aus der Sicht der
Bevölkerung ist es eben wesentlich dass
wir eine bessere Steuerung und Ordnung
im Bereich der Migration
zusammengestalten können und das sind
maßgebliche Punkte die wir ja bereits
gemeinsam verabredet haben und deshalb
begrüßenswert dass jetzt umgesetzt
werden während SPD und Union vor allem
über Verschärfungen reden betonen die
Grünen viel lieber den erleichterten
Zugang für Flüchtlinge zum Arbeitsmarkt
Arbeit als Brücke zum Bleiberecht wer
hier länger ist raus aus den
Sozialtransfers rein in die
Beschäftigung das muss das Motto sein
und wenn man sich da bewährt und sich
hier verdient macht dann soll man
erstens auch was verdienen können und
dann soll man auch gerne in Deutschland
bleiben können zwei verlorene Wahlen der
Ampel und täglich steigender
Migrationsdruck am Freitag will
mit friedichz über einen deutschlandpakt
verhandeln 5 Wochen nach seiner
Ankündigung sass wir genau das tun was
die Bürger und Bürger von uns wollen
nämlich an einem strank ziehen und in
die gleiche Richtung ob alle mitziehen
stand heute ist das allerdings noch
offen nächster stand Freitag hier auch
in dieser Sendung so jetzt geht's um
Schuhe und um die Börse Hanna bringt
beides zusammen ja lange galten die
Schuhe von Birkenstock als ökosandalen
doch diese Zeiten sind längst vorbei der
Schuhhersteller mit deutschen Wurzeln
hat heute sein börsendebü an der Wall
Street gefeiert Frank betmann was
verspricht sich das Unternehmen von
diesem Schritt und wie verlief der
Börsengang ja der traditionsreiche
sandalenhersteller ist in den letzten
Jahren stark gewachsen und hat
gleichzeitig einen bemerkenswerten
imageewandel vollzogen weniger
gesundheitslatschen viel mehr
modeacessoire bürkenstockschuhe sind
Bund und zum Lifestyle Produkt geworden
besonders in den USA doch der Umbau der
Marke hat Geld gekostet Geld dass man
sich durch den Börsengang heute
zumindest zu einem Teil zurückgeholt hat
ein Großteil des Erlöses von gut
anderthalb Milliarden Dollar aber fließt
nicht ins Unternehmen sondern an einen
US Finanzinvestor hinterdem vor allem
der französische Luxuskonzern LVMH steht
Louis von Mu
NSI warum ist die Wahl denn eigentlich
auf die Börse in New York gefallen und
nicht auf Frankfurt wenn es um Glanz und
glämmer geht da hat die Metropole New
York einfach mehr zu bieten dann ist die
USA für bürkenstock inzwischen der
bedeutendste Absatzmarkt und der
wichtigste Grund vielleicht du kannst
dort in der Regel einen besseren Preis
für deine Aktien erzielen gut für
bkenstock schlecht für die Aktionäre wie
sich jetzt am Abend herausgestellt hat
denn der erste gehandelte Kurs an der
Wall Street lag deutlich unter dem
Ausgabepreis eine große
Enttäuschung vielen Dank Frank für diese
ein
die Bundesregierung geht davon aus dass
die deutsche Wirtschaft in diesem Jahr
schrumpft in ihrer Herbstprojektion
rechnet sie mit einem Rückgang der
Wirtschaftsleistung um
0,4% im Frühjahr hatte die Prognose noch
bei Plus 0,4% gelegen
Wirtschaftsminister habck sieht die
Ursachen unter anderem in der Inflation
und den steigenden Zinsen für
2024 rechnet die Regierung mit einem
Wachstum von 1,3%
die Gewerkschaften des öffentlichen
Dienstes wollen für die
Tarifbeschäftigten der Bundesländer eine
Lohnerhöhung von 10,5% durchsetzen
mindestens aber 500 € mehr im Monat das
haben werdi und der deutsche Beamtenbund
heute bekannt gegeben die
Tarifverhandlungen für die rund 1,1
Millionen Beschäftigten beginnen am 26
Oktober zu den Lottozahlen an diesem
Mittwoch die lauten 3 16 25 30 31 42
Superzahl 3 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr auch das auslandsjournal gleich
mit mehr über den drohenden Flächenbrand
im Nahen Osten die aufgeheizte Stimmung
in Israels Nachbarstaaten und eine
Reportage über Familien auf der
verzweifelten Suche nach
Angehörigen es sind keine einfachen
Zeiten morgen führt Sie Anne gellineck
hier durch die Welt und ich sage Danke
fürs
Interesse und wir empfehlen Ihnen
außerdem noch unser heute journal Update
gegen 0:25 Uhr mit Christopher wermann
vom gesamten Team einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend manche fragen sich
wann es denn mal wieder in der Mitte und
im Süden Deutschlands regnet also bis
Montagabend kommt da doch ein bisschen
was zusammen in badenwürtemberg können
das so 5 bis 30 ler pro quadrater werden
im Nordwesten sogar 70 bis 100 l pro
quadratmeer aber der Reihe nach heute
Nacht zieht diese Kaltfront hier weiter
Richtung Mittelgebirge die erreicht sie
etwa morgen früh dann aber passiert mit
dieser Kaltfront nur noch wenig von
Westen kommen neue Regenwolken hinterher
und dann verabschieden sich die Richtung
Osten heute Nacht ist es also noch mal
klar in Süddeutschland da kann sich
lokal wieder Nebel bilden und in dieser
kaltfon kann sich in Norddeutschland
auch mal ein Gewitter entwickeln unter
den dichteren Wolken bleibt die Nacht
mild bei 16 bis 11° Kühler wird's an der
Ostsee oder auch in Bayern mit 10 oder
9°. und morgen wird für die meisten von
uns ein eher bedeckter Tag mit Regen nur
in Süddeutschland bleibt's noch bei dem
freundlichen Mix aus Sonne und Wolken
und hinter der Kaltfront werden die
Wolken aufreißen im Nordosten da liegen
dann die Höchsttemperaturen nur noch es
war ja eine Kaltfront bei 14 15°. im
Süden werden wir gegen 22 bis 27 gr
erreicht und am Freitag sind das dann
deutschlandweit sogar 17 bis 29° und
dann stürzen die Temperaturen ab am
Sonntag oder am Montag sind das nur noch
8 bis 14° und dazu wird es auch deutlich
wechselhafter ich wünsche ihn noch einen
schönen Abend